hey guys happy iPad / launch day I'm
pretty pumped ordered it last night at
midnight and now we're gonna go get some
breakfast and then pick it up and wait
for the Apple store to open Maddy's
gonna have a fun day today you guys
actually haven't seen him in vlogs in a
while he's so big Maddy look how big you
are
hey do another um a venti Cup comparison
from when he was in tough
also a health update he's been so much
better so I changed his food he's now on
only one single type of kangaroo food I
quit doing the raw diet that's good for
some dogs but I guess sometimes not so
good but Maddy has been feeling so much
better no more itching hey buddy
oh you're ripping off my shoelaces it's
cool doesn't even matter he's gonna be
pumped about this new iPod though it's
gonna be so great for his deejaying
let's go look at that pup wild and free
he's got about an hour and the Apple
store opens thankfully I don't have to
sleep outside today
neither does Jenna they had the
pre-order online for in-store pickup or
you could have a trip to your house
which would be here on Friday today is
currently Wednesday so I can't wait till
Friday look at him he's so insane look
at us we are not sleeping outside today
daddy
at brunch
it's actually breakfast it was actually
about this usually we're here for lunch
that's true
djay once he gets first gig
he's so cute okay everyone's gonna love
him
he's sleepy sleepy doggy naughty need a
coffee
I don't
resident gonna fight well he's just like
honey Oh baby he didn't see it
time to go to the office or get that
iPad Maddie's ready to go look at him
yeah let's bring you man come on yep oh
I don't think I like I feel okay
Maddie's first apples to her visit oh
honey I'll just they're gonna be like we
saw Microsoft reading him today oh my
gosh he did Microsoft favorited
retweeted and liked a couple of his twin
let me mix it straighter Oh gotcha
Patti stealing things are you trying to
steal stuff okay I might have had a
little shopping spree so I'm gonna have
some fun stuff to unbox video I'm so
excited
she decided for mommy's present soon she
resided for the prison's we've got the
new it says the Logitech Keyboard I'm
gonna be interested to see the
comparison between that and then these
SmartConnect one which should be here
soon so I'll do a comparison of that I
also got it's an Apple charger
nightstand so I'm excited to test that a
lightning cable job like you know I have
beauty gurus do like clothing hauls but
I do Apple store hauls I got a new
lightning cable connector of course the
iPad so I'll be doing that unboxing if I
haven't done it already on my channel
but right now we're gonna take a nap
we're let's take a nap woah look at this
look at this look at you nerds it
actually looks really cool in here
though first received a you can't call
me a nerd I'm like a first for so I'm
halfway there I asked that to be a nerd
is not it's okay it's we don't you I'm
not into the game
no I want to see this clip saved in my
oh yeah yeah show me a service you'll
see this on Facebook girls soon I'll
tell you when it's ready I got a fast
for a little bit here hey you have this
on the toilet yeah it's yeah good
is out there Jeezy's been kind of blown
up he's good
music look at him oh he looks so cute
first but I like the mix of like the
Koreans yeah lar you about the prestige
I just did Percy trying to figure out
what I should unlock permanently oh
because every time force teach you get
one choice to unlock so yeah permanently
I'm gonna do ghosts because people get
UAVs a lot here when you have ghosts
you could you it'd be so quick I feel
like every second I get home a lot goes
do it boom oh god I love this song who
is this this is Amber run the song is
called I found I can listen to it on
repeat I just check out these prestige
one stats let's check them out 2.11 ke
not bad that is really good what's mine
I'm at my KDS negative oh yeah you guys
probably want to check that especially
because I when I play domination at
killing anybody
I had one ruthless metal which i think
is 20 kills in robot die what I sure got
it
I should have nuclear when I screwed up
it's almost like you were a pro at one
point like that not in mediums I didn't
know what's on duty but like don't worry
I said it so I'm going to get my hair
done
I never know what's going to happen when
I go in because sometimes I'm like you
know what I think I want to go a little
darker today so I might or I might not
we'll see tips this vlog is probably it
could be potentially one of my worst I
don't even know what happened there's
probably like eight days worth of
footage in this video so we're working
on some tracks for Maddie hi JB how's it
going hey don't let them hear Oh phew oh
my goodness Jana's over there editing of
God some furniture that is being
assembled a lot of things are going on
but Maddie and I were chatting and he
was like okay I really like the sound of
this but I think that the beat needs to
drop a little bit sooner I was like oh
my god you're right JB is like wow
you're right he was working on some
loops we're recording vocals tomorrow so
it'll be great
Jenna please he's doing the vlog
Maddie we're recording vocals tomorrow I
hope you're ready honey we have - we've
got listed I know you're tired I know
you're tired but listen I need you to
work on this baby this is this is this
is your life this is the life that you
chose play it oh that's good
good work do you like this do you think
that sounds ok or like should we maybe
that was good babe that was nice
oh that's good oh you like that that's a
nice one oh we're an artist I need some
T's D I needs to get some T's I want
Maddie to know that Maddie's all right
Maddie go right here hey what's this
what's right here some T's in the trap
two T's in the trap
honestly vocal recording is gonna go
really well tomorrow for sure
I think it's gonna be great uh-huh his
Studios over here right over there
Maddie's eatin a lot of T's today so
pick up here he is gaining I agree
that's good that was a good one okay
let's see what else you got okay I'm
recording so play us something oh that's
good I love what you're doing with it I
love what you're doing with it
great good no that's the keyboard good
boy this is nice I can't believe it how
long did your his first track is gonna
be so killer do you want to add anything
to it or what's going on cuz we can we
can honestly we can we can make changes
anytime you want do you like this or do
what do you think about like a drum
track we're gonna definitely need we
have to have a squeak at part okay
you're sleeping you're so cute he's so
tired
it is a titty oh god you're good Oh
get all those legs in there
I'm so good nah it's incredible oh wow
you're so talented good boy
what bit of music he's so ready for bed
hey guys how are you today I'm going to
be unboxing the new iPad pro which is
massive